hello everybody how's everybody doing
hope you're doing fine
first up we're gonna mention again sorry
will for the next couple weeks that we
have a conference in Lusaka Zambia all
those who want to participate they have
a chance to buy their ticket starting
today so get your suitcases ready if you
want to see an exotic land okay and if
you have the chance and I wanted to
mention that the other day you know I
inaugurated my new site web site known
as rope hypothesis calm and I put up a
book PDF format that you can download
some people had trouble with that I
guess that's to some degree but fixed as
far as I'm concerned there were there
were there was a couple people who
provided feedback now I wanted to put
you up to to put you up to date on that
and this is the site okay and if you go
up there where it says books you'll find
a book okay you can download it's known
as the rope hypothesis tells you how to
download it ok just click on the link
that's in that on that page
ok we've modified the page a little bit
today but you should be able to find it
and get this thing here a couple of the
feedbacks that I got one person said
there was an error and so we fixed that
here today so if you want to download
the book up again let me show you where
the error is
okay there was on this page you will see
that on that page it'll say it's a page
with 19 and we got the short links
confused with a long
okay so if you look at the long links up
on the top that's how it was now the new
one says exactly in Reverse what
confused us and with the reason we
didn't pick up on this is that you can
see the waves coming out of the prism
okay they have longer waves and the ones
inside the prism that is totally an
error on the part of the mainstream
that's a bad way to illustrate it and we
saw that and it just escaped our our
mind and misled us to believe that you
know for a second there and so we didn't
catch it yeah it's the other way around
when it goes from the prism to air
you're going from supposedly a denser
medium to a lighter medium and somehow
according to the establishment light
speeds up something accelerates light
back to 300,000 kilometers per second so
if a prism is made out of glass glasses
anywhere in the 1.45 21.5 refractive
index that means it travels
approximately at 200,000 kilometers per
second through the prism and then it
speeds up back to 300,000 how light does
that well you get asked the
mathematicians about that yeah under
under the rope model light always
travels at the same speed we between any
two atoms whether it's the prism whether
it's air whether its water and liquids
gases solids it doesn't matter always at
the same throughout the entire universe
the speed of light is the same why
because torsion is the same why because
the speed of light is C little C 300,000
kilometers per second between any two
atoms that's a it's a torsion okay and
all we change is and here I can
illustrate that all we change is you
know the number of links and the length
of each link and then when you know when
you have longer wavelengths essentially
long link lengths you have fewer links
so that's the trade-off between
frequency and wavelength which we call
under the rope model because link
anyways we corrected then a couple other
minor hairs but you'll see that in the
new book so you may need to download it
again sorry about that but these things
do happen this fellow who pointed that
out
his name is Gabor he also proposed to
translate the book to Hungarian and I
guess Gabor is like Zsa Zsa Gabor maybe
it's a very common name and hungry for
all I know you know maybe it's like
Smith anyways he's gonna translate he
proposed translating to Hungarian and
I'm gonna be translating to Spanish I in
fact I am already translating into
Spanish so we got two languages anybody
else who has like a mother tongue which
is not English once it's a translator
well you know they can contact us at
here and talk acha acha
that's me holding a rope there by the
way you know okay okay so there it is
that's the picture essentially and yeah
you can contact us at okok
Hotmail and tell us that you know if you
want to translate the book okay and
we'll send you a file and word file you
can translate and send it back and we'll
give you credit for it for obviously and
we'll also put your name on the honour
list ok another comment that was made my
good friend monkey mind and he said the
father he said that sorry got the moment
yeah he said that he there's a question
of whether the thread unwinds from the
rope when it's spinning and creates this
magnetic field it's a good question we
never resolved that that's that's at
least to my satisfaction I have not
resolved it in my mind
there are possibilities one is that the
thread unwinds he was suggesting only
one thread unwinds the other ones
remained straight which was my original
notion my son came up with unscreened up
with this notion of double threads which
I thought was a little more logical
I still cannot vouch for it and I
propose even a third one which is that
maybe it's the valence thread the one
that's on the outside of like an atom
that maybe swings around like we showed
in one of the pages there oh is it page
58 and and so you have this you know
when you form a molecule between two
atoms and it's an ionic bond one one
shell goes through the other okay and so
maybe there's a process similar to that
going on with what we call the magnetic
field in other words the lines of force
and so there are different possibilities
I think the main issue like I told him
in a letter is the following okay so let
me point that out for those of you want
to tackle the problem and it looks like
this we have to identify what those
lines of force are they when you
sprinkle iron filings over a magnet you
know they align in a certain way and
it's always the same way in other words
you always see a similar pattern you can
see it there on your upper right you can
see it there on your upper left okay
those are the patterns you're gonna see
and so the question is you know the
mathematicians say well you know those
lines of force don't really exist even
though Faraday said it clearly says you
know those are physical lines but
they've disregarded and he had a lot of
experience with magnets you know
observing and testing them and paying
around with them but they said you know
the official version that a mainstream
version is that those lines of force are
only used for explanation
or for trying to describe what's
happening and whether magnetic fields
and but they don't really exist well we
got a problem with that notion because
that means that if those lines of force
are moving the iron filings on the one
hand and also creating attraction
they've had better be more than angels
and spirits they had better be real the
fact that we can't see them and touch
them that does not make them unreal any
and this is the problem we have so I
think the bottom line with the threads
is we don't really know exactly how
they're created whether they're
separation between two atoms that are
not touching or not merged for example
you know the serpentine there that you
see under lower right
it's a serpentine that means all those
atoms are merged and they spin around
and that's what we are saying that is
the magnetic field the spinning around
of the threads that come out of those
mergers and the issue is whether you
know you have a situation like the
crystal there that what that's use the
crystal lattice that you see up there in
the center up upper center where you see
that they're all connected like by bed
bedsprings that's the way the
establishment shows many of the crystal
lattices and they say look you know all
these atoms are connected as if they
were connected by bed springs in other
words they vibrate with respect to each
other and etc etc and the question is
whether the atoms are merged shall
tishell or whether they are separated by
ropes that's the issue and if they're
separated by ropes then this notion that
monkey mind raised which is the top one
whether it's one thread or two threads
that come out of the rope that's one
issue and the other one is that you know
maybe it's the electron shell one of the
threads are out of the electron shell
that's coming loose even though they're
merged so there are different
possibility that people would have to
analyze each one my point again is that
we have to explain those the the lines
of force and the lines of force are what
make up the magnetic field and the lines
of force this so-called magnetic field
causes a force through for example a
coil a live coil is a solenoid okay so
it causes a force and hopefully that
force is not mediated by spirits again
hopefully there is a physical object
moving in that region the fact that we
can't see it or touch it ourselves
doesn't mean that those lines of force
are not real and the other thing that
you should keep in mind if you want to
tackle the problem is what I'm showing
you on the lower right there in green
all the green little balls those atoms
which are merged when they swing they
could be staggered the threads could be
staggered in fact the first one would
swing first before the second one the
third one the fourth went down the line
when it when the current starts flowing
and so they start speeding and when they
spin they swing these threads around in
a and those threads would not be on the
same plane that's the point that I'm
trying to make okay so they would be
staggered and so that's another factor
that you might want to consider when you
if you want to tackle this problem on a
figure out you know how the magnetic
field is made by not angels not lines of
force but threads physical threads
physical meaning not that you can touch
or see it physical means that it has
shape okay and again the definitions
here are crucial anyways those things
easy to be clarified so let's get on now
with the subject matter of today and
that's gonna be mr. Aquinas and his
buddy niels bohr and as you know they've
been debating seriously not against each
other but in favor of each other one guy
does it with particles the other guy
does it with angels but the properties
of particles of quantum today and the
properties that and attributes that
angels had in the 13th century in the
days of Saint Thomas Aquinas or
better known now as st. Thomas a quantum
okay is that you know they have the same
properties the same attributes they they
had the same superpowers okay so what's
the issue the issue is we need to know
what physics is because that's where it
all starts because these people are
doing physics st. Thomas was explaining
motion and time specifically was
applying Aristotle's notion of particles
and points and lines and he extrapolated
them to this notion of time they were
analyzing time okay and so you look up
and you say but what is physics and
because these are issues of physics so
it's quantum mechanics supposedly they
claim to be doing physics so we need to
get to the bottom of this notion of what
is physics and here we have from the IOP
the institute of physics and you know
this is one of the and I and I made
those letters bigger so we can read them
but what they show is you know that
physics has something to do with making
smart phones smarter GPS possible music
portable and an interconnected Internet
okay so they see it as something related
to technology they think that physics
has something to do with technology
this is inertia lots of people have out
there they think physics is all about
you know creating devices and making our
lives more comfortable you know and
we're challenging that notion obviously
it's got nothing to do with it
technology has nothing at all to do with
physics that's what we're gonna argue
here okay and so we have to look up you
know what is the definition of physics
okay let's start there and this is what
we find we find these definitions when
it's in the Wikipedia the other one to
dictionary.com you're gonna look it up
for yourself you'll find something
similar in any dictionaries that you
look it up in physics is the Natural
Sciences studies studies we just study
we gawk
we just sit down
and absorb something whether we
understood it or not we just study it
matter its motion and behavior through
space and time through space and time so
you can travel through time time travel
you know yeah time is this body of water
you travel through okay and the related
entities of energy and force whatever
those are because those are undefined as
well so none of those four words have
ever been defined and that's that's what
they study what is physics according to
dictionary.com science that deals they
don't study they just deal with it with
matter and energy motion and force so
almost the same thing yeah so we have
these notions that these are the
definitions for physics okay
gives us an idea that you know they
don't really have a good handle on on
the definition to begin with you would
think after a thousands of years I mean
who was it Aristotle who invented the
word physics and that's where we got the
word originally from him or his is
Lyceum because there were other people
working at the Lyceum other than him he
just takes the credit today yeah and so
they created this word physics and you
know Aristotle defined it like more or
less like I define it it's trying to
understand mechanisms explanation of how
this universe works that's not the
definition of physics today today they
study and they deal with what energy and
force and who knows what else that has
never been defined has nothing to do
with physics whatsoever and and so
here's another notion and this comes
from a site known as study comm which
they teach physics and other things over
the internet says physics the study
another study they study you know they
don't learn they don't understand they
just study of matter and energy is an
ancient and broad field of science one
thing that may come to mind when you
think of physics is that the many
scientific laws laws we have laws there
there's a legislature you know Congress
they you know you've got all these
representatives and Senators and so on
and I guess they vote for laws
who knows which are statements
describing keyword describe phenomena
that have been repeatedly tested and
confirmed
Ahana confirmed confirmed to whom to the
Catholic Church the who who was this
confirmed to physicists perform and
repeat experiments aha I didn't know
that
I thought technicians did that kind of
work you know
Gophers they go to lab and they do
experiments I thought of physicists as
the guy who does uses his brain not his
hands but I guess they have a different
notion physicists perform and repeat
experiments okay to formulate these laws
and explain how our universe works
notice that they go be between
describing and explaining they started
describing this and we're going to be
described now they explain how these
laws are so thoroughly tested that they
are accepted as truths by whom who
accepts this is true what is it a you
know a group of people up there that
decided for all of us that they're going
to accept this as truth and shove it
down your throat is this what it is and
they can be used to help us predict how
other things will behave uh-huh so now
they're into astrology as well they do
predictions physics explains again
natural phenomena in the universe well
that's kind of funny that they want to
use the word explained because as we
showed the other day here we have
authority okay here we have authority
telling us now that they have no idea
whatsoever how to explain those who are
not shocked when they first come across
quantum theory cannot possibly have
understood it
evolution didn't equip us to be able to
visualize quantum mechanics evolution
did this to us so we have two gurus
there Niels Bohr and Neil Susskind from
the University of Stanford and then we
have our Richard Feynman Nobel Prize he
says I think I can safely say that
nobody understands quantum mechanics did
I keep asking yourself if you can
possibly avoid ER but how can it be like
that nobody knows how it can be like
that the more you see how strangely
nature behaves the harder it is to make
a model that explain
how even the simplest phenomena actually
work so theoretical physics has given up
on that so no they don't have any
explanation not one not one rational
explanation and like finance says you
know they've given up on that they don't
even seek to understand how this
universe works anymore okay so it's it's
beyond what's known as physics so
physics has been a sensitive find it's
not like Aristotle originally you find
it okay and so what do they get out of
all this well here we have the can
Academy another popular site on the
Internet
okay they do physics classes online okay
says physics is the study again study
that word study of the basic principles
that govern the physical world around us
we'll start by looking at motion itself
then we'll learn about forces momentum
energy and other concepts which are
irrelevant to physics in lots of
different physical situations to get the
most out of physics you'll need to you
need a solid understanding of algebra
and a basic understanding of
trigonometry huh I need to learn algebra
at Riga I mean math is is a language and
are these people saying that it's the
language of physics and yeah if you look
it up you'll find comments like you know
here's a couple these are just standard
things that people write is where a
couple gurus wrote in Cora you know pull
them out because this is what the notion
that people have right there is no doubt
that this is a student of advanced
student of so-called physi study in
quantum mechanics he says there is no
doubt that the most important language
of physics is math I cannot imagine how
can people describe the physical process
in quantum world without math describe
maybe certainly not explain the
questions is physics about describing or
about explaining I mean I I described a
chair four legs a backrest and two two
armrests
and or that you know the lion ran and
galloped or whatever 40 km/h and I just
described that in that science I measure
with a clog in the what I get a Nobel
for it though that's science that's
physics just measurement weighing
someone on the scale and saying you
weigh of a hundred pounds that's science
that's physics this is what these people
are saying they're saying it's a
description mathematics is the primary
tool used by physicists to construct
models make measurements and make
predictions again that word prediction
II they're into astrology or something
physicists use algebra calculus
differential equation linear algebra
group Theory topology and more and more
to unveil the mechanisms that occur on
subatomic scales relativistic scales and
everyday scales so here the small things
that all these mathematical line items
are branches of mathematics or whatever
somehow help them unveil mechanisms
what does math have to do with
mechanisms mechanism is an explanation
of how something functioned how does
math help you in any way I mean if you
know that for example the the you you
let go of a pen or a ball or whatever
and you measure its 9.8 meters per
second squared
acceleration towards the center of the
earth does that give you any mechanism
about gravity how gravity actually does
pull that pen or ball to the center of
the year no it doesn't imagine let me
give you a for instance here you go to
the conference so-called physics
conference and you see Michio Kaku one
of the Guru's of mathematical physio you
see Brian Green right and so here's Joey
he sees them in Yi approaches of Brandi
said
Oh mr. green would you please give me an
autograph and so Brian Greene says sir
Joey here is and gives him an autograph
and until he says by the way could you
explain to me how gravity works while
we're at it and pregnant says you know
Joey
in order for you to understand how
gravity works you're gonna have to go to
the University and study Chinese Chinese
study Chinese what do you mean I have to
study Chinese yeah you're gonna have to
study Chinese because that's the
language in which we explain or describe
how the universe works
so Joey said well you know both
languages you know Chinese and English
so can't you translate it for me in
English said well you see Joey it's not
a one-to-one correspondence you know you
can't translate Chinese and English word
for word literally well can you give me
a ballpark notion of how gravity works
maybe just a picture so sure I can do
that well you have this four-dimensional
fish net it's unimaginable
don't try to imagine it's also an
infinite we we try to put it beyond the
mind of the humans but that's a
different story
but the point is you put a bowling ball
on this net and it weighs down and
everything falls in it and as that's
gravity it's the warpage of space-time
and Joey says but tight time you know
you're working time but time is is a
concept is how can you work time well
Joey I told you you need to study
Chinese in order to understand what I'm
telling you how gravity work because
unless you know Chinese you won't really
understand it and so on it goes on and
on these people say you got to study a
language called math you got to be
expert in math
and if you want to understand gravity
and you say well can't you translate it
for me well here's the translation the
four-dimensional fishnet that's warped
that's gravity it's geometry geometry of
space-time and you see but that includes
time time as a concept you say yeah you
got to go to the university and learn
all this math stuff you got to learn the
language or you got to be conditioned
right to the language is that what it is
so what is the language of mathematics
well mathematics is a language of
adverts quantitative adverbs mathematics
does not deal with objects and it
doesn't deal with verbs it doesn't care
about verbs such as running or swimming
that's no good in mathematics you need
to know how fast how much how much time
you need to have the numbers and units
in order to use any of that any of those
verbs in mathematics and that's an
adverb that's a qualifier of a verb your
qualifying you're modifying the verb so
so mathematics is a language only
exclusively of quantitative adverbs in
fact it doesn't use adjectives it
doesn't use verbs and it doesn't use
objects at all has no use for any of
that you know you bring a tray and the
guy said what am I going to do with
three well can't you put it in an
equation someone at home I can I can put
the mass of the tree I can put the size
of you know how fast the tree was
brought all that stuff I can put an
equation
I can't bring I can't put the tree in
there I can't put running in there I
can't put the adjective green or the
word big in there I need a number I need
to put 10 meters or five pounds I need
to put a number in there followed by
units then I can use that stuff and so
the issue is they developed the language
a very exclusive language of
quantitative adverbs and here let me
give you a for instance because see
under the wrote under rational science
under rational physics if you're gonna
stick around you're gonna have to learn
a new language but the good part about
this language is that it's going to
empower you
I'm not kidding you it's good power
you're gonna have super power suddenly
you you're gonna have the mind of God so
to speak you're gonna read up a paper by
of the you know advanced literature of
so-called scientific literature or even
blogs you know where they bring it down
to the layman and you're gonna be able
to spot all the heirs one right after
another listen this is the idea
okay I can't go into great detail today
but I'll give you a good feel for what
I'm saying here okay
see these are adjectives in ordinary
speech okay we have infinite
infinitesimal continuous straight
perpendicular and so on well in rational
science and rational physics we divide
these up we say look at verse qualify
motion and adjectives qualify objects
it's black or white straightforward
we can't confuse and we can't use
adjectives to qualify firms and we can't
use adverbs to qualify objects and so
it's very important to determine when
someone is talking giving you a
presentation in a conference or whatever
or even if you read their paper or
whatever to distinguish and figure out
exactly what is he saying what is up
what is an object in his sentence and
what is a verb okay I'm gonna get to
that in a second I'll give you some
examples and you can see the word
parallel there on the bottom you say
well what is parallel there under
adverbs isn't parallel like you know two
lines kind of like the equal sign right
and yeah let me give you an idea of
what's wrong with with this word
parallel see the way it's defined today
in geometry
it's lines that do not meet they have
the second corollary so to speak equi
distant like saying they're the same
thing and they're not these two are two
different kinds of definition what is a
verb I like my verbs green so I painted
any anything that's verb I put it in
green so that people can spot it
immediately and say oh he's talking
about
and I put my nouns in brown now if you
don't like it maybe a racist or whatever
but you can change the colors any way
you want no problem but the point here
is life that do not meet me is a verb
and so this is the dynamic definition of
parallel lines it's not the same of
equidistant which just means that you
know these lines maintain a single
distance okay and they involve objects a
line is an object it's that
two-dimensional plane that you see there
in brown and all we're looking at is the
distance and making sure that the
spacing between it we don't care we
don't measure we just say you know the
spacing has to be exactly the same
between the two lines and that's a queer
distance so it's just it's a photograph
it's a still image whereas the parallel
lines that do not mean you know how do
you know they do not meet you know that
first of all that's motion but then how
do you know they do not meet at infinity
I mean maybe if you go another mile they
meet so how long are we going to take
these lines that are used by
mathematical physicists and geometers
and they say yeah outlines that do not
meet well do not meet where I mean a
line is not really a line because they
say it extends until infinity and what
are you gonna go all the way to infinity
you find out if they meet or not this is
a proof this is a in operational
definition which is totally unscientific
and so you know we put it under adverbs
their definition because lines that do
not meet is a qualifier what they're
saying is is a qualifier verbs what
they're trying to tell you is that you
know you got to perform some kind of
experiment and there's motion involved
it's a dynamic definition and so you
can't accept that in geometry because
again what we're saying is parallel
lines have to be it's a static concept
you don't have to do anything and these
people are saying yeah you got to do you
got to go all the way to infinity and
find out they meet and so these are the
notions that we're gonna be showing that
there's a difference between what you
find in mathematical physics
we propose in as an alternative in
rational physics and here's a list of
other famous nouns which are really
verbs orbit orbital infinity motion
movement change itinerary trajectory all
these are verbs as far as physics is
concerned these people treat them as
nouns and more than Kennedy they really
reify them and they come into being you
know the take for example the orbital
you're below has many orbits of an
electron bead around the atom and so you
say well the region where you can find
the electron bead rolling around or
wherever it jumps or whatever we're
gonna cover that whole region we're
gonna call that in orbital that's where
they got the word the word orbital
essentially comes from orbit so they've
turned many orbit many hula hoops into
this ball which they called an orbital
and then it's it's a again it's a vague
notion even in that sense but all these
words are verbs and so you don't treat
them as nouns okay
and so this causes a lot of problems and
until you can master the language of
rational physics you're gonna have
trouble
so as homework maybe you should consider
reading a blog or a paper it could be
even from a what is it a one of these
sites that popularize this physics
space.com or one of those or strana me
magazine and you'll find articles which
are readable which are not so technical
in their language and you're gonna spot
the arrows immediately if you use that
this criterion you're gonna go in there
and say okay which in this sentence what
is the noun what is the verb does that
noun include motion within it if does it
embody motion and so on down the line
and then you're gonna say well how do
they qualify they used an adjective to
qualify a verb they use an adverb to
qualify it what is truly an a noun a an
object and so on you're gonna be able
spot that suddenly you're gonna be able
to see
much more of the world than what you've
read so far you know you really got to
put your mind into using this this new
method of analyzing you know what's out
there
here are others these are static nouns
okay they put it over here again you
know these are these are not nouns okay
for the purposes of physics universe is
not a noun
okay we can't talk about the universe
okay it's a concept it's a relation
between space and matter
that's it includes both words it's a
someone establishes a relation by using
that word by the definition itself space
vacuum ether
what's ether many many particles that's
what it is location position all these
words are concepts you can't use them as
objects point line
you know we discussed that a couple
sessions ago point is if you're
referring to the dot that's a physical
object and if you're referring to what
it represents the location then you're
talking about a concept and so you can't
use them both in one you got to decide
is the word point refers to the dot or
does it refer to location you can't have
it both ways God cannot be both an
object and a concept that's the question
that's the issue and yeah what is this
language for what do they use these
these terms for well let me give you for
instance here here you'll see you know
you you might come across an inclined
plane okay and they say okay I
understand that it's a ball rolling down
a may inclined plane very simple right
but that's not this is no use of no use
in mathematics so what they do is they
say no no look it's not what you have is
mass rolling down okay it's mass that is
rolling down and you say well why is it
going down well it's going down because
it's being pushed by force
and you have time transpiring in other
words you got a clock that's rolling and
what it all creates is this energy right
that is some kind of spirit that comes
in and fills the equations and so this
is the way it's explained this is this
is the mathematical language the
language of physics is here that's the
language of physics okay so you're gonna
have a difference between how a
mathematician talks in our rational
individual talks especially rational
physics and you need to look at the
especially you know which ones are the
nouns which ones are the verbs and these
people are just moving moving concepts
and they're qualifying them with the
wrong qualifier whether you know if
they're gonna be moving mass they can't
say green mass okay they're not going to
use an adjective for that
what because mass is not a physical
object so you can say the green ball
roll because you're applying an
adjective to qualify the ball
that's that standard that's no problem
there but you can't use green to qualify
the word mass or energy or any of those
words and for that you need an adverb
that which again shows you that the word
they're using is a is not a noun it's
it's a concept usually a verb that's
been reified and converted into a noun
and that's the language of mathematics
which they claimed as the language of
physics so you see where I'm going with
all this anyways we had the same problem
with mr. Aquinas okay Thomas Aquinas
Tommy and what he did was he used the
same type of language why because he
used the words that he got from wrote it
and then we get this old one here the
words he got from Aristotle okay so
those are the words I use and here we
have you know the what we were looking
at in the past weeks we have mr. Aquinas
on one side we have mr. four on the
other and we dealt with the first few
issues there
where Thomas was analyzing how angels
behaved and what properties they had and
they match exactly the ones that quantum
mechanics has assigned to their
particles the last two are the ones we
still have not covered and the first one
is whether an angel or a particle can
pass through an intermediate space and
whether the movement of an angel or a
particle for that matter is
instantaneous and so let's answer the
first one by by mr. Tommy there okay let
me put myself back in here and get
myself in there so he uses this notion
he says um let me get this other one
first
hold it give me a second here so we put
it in the right context somebody is
there some sometimes difficult to get in
there he was a answer whether an angel
passes through the intermediate space
and for that he's gonna have to use the
term he's gonna have to analyze the same
word that Aristotle analyzed which is
the word continues okay and so he says
the local motion of an angel can be
continuous and non continuous okay so it
could be you one or the other if it be
continuous the angel cannot pass from
one extreme to another without passing
through the mid space because as is set
by the philosopher and that's he called
Aristotle the philosopher and he goes in
and analyzes you know some of the what
Aristotle wrote in his book physics and
this is the critical point which
Aristotle has in his book v which is the
one mentioned by Thomas here he says
points can touch while units can only be
in succession moreover there can always
be something between points for all
lines are intermediate between points
what is he talking about well when he
says line here he's talking about
distance but business is represented
with a line and we're really he's
talking about distance travelled and so
he's saying you can travel from point to
point that space he calls a line
whereas edy is not necessary that there
should be should possibly be anything
between units huh what is he talking
about before there can be nothing
between the numbers 1 & 2 so you can see
that we're talking about continuous and
what is continues well under and the
rational science under rational language
continuous is an adjective it cannot be
used to analyze what these folks are
doing here they should use the word
incessant because they're talking about
motion so they can talk about constant
motion incessant motion but not about
continuous motion continues as an
adjective and applies to tables you can
say a continues table if it were made of
a single piece but when you talk about
motion you can't use the word continues
you're not in physics in an ordinary
speech yeah but not in fizzing physics
continues as an adjective and you have
to use an adverb and an adverb is like
incessant and you can say but incessant
is an adjective in ordinary speech not
in rational science in rational science
incessant can only be applied to verbs
to motion to dynamic scenarios so you
would say incessant motion continuous
table that's the way we use the language
you can say incessant table and likewise
you can say continuous motion and these
people are using the word continues to
define to apply it to you know they're
talking about time and motion
and then suddenly I don't know where
this guy says Aristotle says oh by the
way the numbers you know they you know
you get the one in the tune there's
nothing in between them how do we jump
to numbers you know it's like they're
mixing all kinds of nonsense in there
and giving you examples that out of
nowhere that have nothing to do with the
subject at hand and this is this is what
you're gonna see not only through with
Aristotle and
st. Thomas Aquinas a quantum but you're
gonna see what Bohr as well
and so here's the crucial part that st.
Thomas was trying to say okay I think
this is the bottom line on his analysis
of that and that's why Lynne Angels
moved locally his essence is applied to
various places that's how he saw that he
says yeah the angel can be compassionate
me in immediate space why because even
though he's locally like circumscribed
to a space of sorts he his essence his
soul the soul of the a joke because the
angel is soul is applied you know
everywhere so he gets the both of us
both worlds without justifying he's just
making this magical analysis and since
he an angel can can be compassed through
intermediate space just like he can be
everywhere at once like we discussed the
other day he can also pass her
intermediate space because he's already
there he's already on the other side and
so how does a quantum mechanics answer
this well we answer that the other day
with John Rennie the guy from who ran
who it was at Scientific American and he
says the photons do not have
well-defined trajectory the diagram
shows them as if they were little balls
traveling along a well-defined path
however the photons are delocalized and
don't have a specific position and
direction of motion so we're not talking
about you know photons like being
particle he's introducing magic here
just like st. Thomas's the photon is
basically a fuzzy sphere expanding away
from the source and overlapping both
slits so here we have you know this wave
the spherical wave that is instantaneous
because you know the wave function can
collapse and turn into a point and the
point or the dot or the particle or the
corpus or whatever they want to call it
suddenly can the the construct itself or
the more
and suddenly that thing covers the
entire universe as a wave because the
wave has no end point and so it's more
or less like st. Thomas angel there that
is not only moved locally but he can
apply it to various places and that's
the magic of the wave the wave can
collapse through a particle whatever
particle is and then the particle can
also turn into a way that the tip of the
magic wand of the magician hey or math
magician so he says the photon is
basically a fuzzy sphere spanning away
from the source and overlapping both
slits that's why it goes through both
slits so if you want to know why the
light goes through both slits well
because it goes out as a photon it then
turns into a wave it covers the whole
room and then it condenses back into a
particle on the other side of the slits
for whatever reasons that's magic yeah
that doesn't give us any insight
whatsoever in how you know the
experiment works and he said the photon
position is only well-defined when we
collapse its wavefunction so they take a
wave function which is a concept they
collapse it they turn it into a particle
which is another concept because
according to at least Sean Carroll it's
a excited field which is a concept right
so they play around with these words
it's none of them are nouns all of these
are verbs or concepts of some kind okay
usually they're verbs and then yeah so
you can see why you know there's no
difference between st. Thomas's angels
and quantum mechanics particles so
called particles whatever particles are
because they never do you find that work
very well and then there's the other
issue the remaining issue was whether a
whether a what is it a an angel can move
instantaneously and it's what Aquinas
has to say so the local movement of an
angel is instantaneous but that's the
local movement
okay they said that when an Angels moved
from place to place during the whole of
the preceding time he is in the term
where from but in the last instant of
such time he is in the term where to
says from where I'm from and to where
okay kind of thing nor is there any need
for the a medium between the terms just
as there is no medium between time and
the limit of time so there's no medium
that's that's how you say so so in a way
the the angel you know can move
instantaneously because there's no
medium between time 1 and time infinity
or whatever and just to cut across and
we can go to that last line says an
angel can be in one place in one instant
and in another place in the next instant
without any time intervening okay now
that isn't that satellite quantum and a
little bit like like general relativity
as well right
and so what is the answer of quantum
mechanics to that I mean you know do
they have anything even similar to that
and you know of course they've come up
with the same notion okay and they've
done it for particles and for
essentially all of mathematical physics
and this is what they came up with you
know Heisenberg came up with the
uncertainty principle that means that
you can't tell the position and momentum
of a particle simultaneously the more
you know about one the less you know
about the other you've heard of Spock
and the crew you know Captain Kirk and
so on teleportation you heard of that
you know it's instantaneous movement
you don't go between your reassembled
destination and totally you know the
leaves as a particle goes as a wave goes
across the barrier and then arrives as a
particle on the other side and so it's
like either you can interpret that two
ways either the thing just went from one
location to another without passing
through the locations in between or as
Aquinas says you can go to from Spain to
Syria or I can think of going from Spain
to Syria without passing through Italy
that's Aquinas explains
and that's more or less with these
people saying that's what tunneling is
you go from Spain to Syria yeah and you
don't have to go through Italy okay
the the the the particle starts out
turns into a wave stretches its neck
across the finish line and our and it's
detected as a particle on the other side
it's a yeah the particle just made it
through tunneling what is tunneling it
means if there is no time between
starting and put an ending point
that's essentially what it is they're
they're getting rid of time they're
saying you know somehow the particle is
already there before you know almost at
the same time it left and so there's no
time in-between and they say well it's
very simple the the wave stretches or
occupies the whole universe or what was
already there and then when you're gonna
measure it collapses into a particle
instantaneously always right and so
there's no motion there's no time it's
just instant and so these people have
all arrived that's the same today
quantum mechanics as arrived at the same
conclusions that mr. st. Thomas Aquinas
upon arrived at almost a thousand years
ago that's the status quo and yeah all
this is related because the arguments
for st. that underlined st. Thomas
Aquinas a--'s arguments the the
underlying arguments are all come from
Aristotle he's the guy who came up with
this notion or at least he's the guy who
wrote about it because I think it came
even 200-300 years earlier where they
talked about particles and they took
that particle they talked about points
and he talked about lines and that's
what they use to describe location what
they used to describe distance and
specifically distance travels not
distances in separation but in distance
that you have to move through
displacement okay and that's what they
use they use the line for this placement
they use the dot
to represent the point but the the
location they called this one appoint
this one align and that's what they
based all their analysis and st. Thomas
Aquinas borrowed all that he did an
analysis on angels showing how they can
go from one place to another without
going to intermediate spaces because
they have all these super powers and
quantum mechanics have picked up on that
in a roaring 20s and they said oh we can
do the same thing you know these
particles just go from here to there
without going through the intermediate
space and they can be in two places at
once
and many can be at one place at the same
time and so on down the line they have
all these magical superpowers are those
explanations first of all you need to
understand the language and if you
understand the language and you
understand that mathematical physics is
you know the underlying languages
mathematics and mathematics is only a
language of quantitative adverbs and
they have trouble you know qualifying
nouns and verbs because they go back and
forth they use adjectives for verbs they
use adverbs for nouns then once you pick
up on that language then you can see
real quickly when you read a you know
like a something that's been translated
from the official the technical
magazines into layman's magazines you're
going to be able to to read and say hold
it is this guy talking is that a noun is
that in is in orbit all a noun is motion
a noun for the purposes of physics is an
itinerary a noun once you look at all
these things you just you realize that
what they've done is reified the
language there they're using verbs as
nouns and then they're qualifying it
with adverbs and what they're actually
doing is using an advert to qualify a
noun an object that that's been reified
as a noun that's that's what they're
doing and so you have all this mixture
the only way you're gonna get to the
bottom of that is identifying what
really is a noun what really is a verb
what's inadvertent
an adjective that's the language that
mathematical physics has never yet
mastered all they uses quantitative bad
boys anyways we will continue with
geometry next time around and if you
have again any issues with the book if
you find any more errors so to speak
well let me know you get it to toca Kaka
at hotmail calm and we'll be glad to
listen to you thank you and we'll see
you what is it on Sunday we'll see you
then bye bye